Hey, it's me and...Marzia!
She's back everyone, how does it feel? I dunno weird. ha ha hu
Its been a long time, Its been a long time,
hisashiburi desu
I thought why don't we answer some questions? Cause
all the time People are like Oh, what is happening with Marzia?
Is she hiding in your basement. Is she having a pug factory?
What is she doing?
how is Marzia doing and what is Marzia doing?
(Laughs) Pug factory. Well, first of all your in, your clay studio.
Yeah, I was working and then you were just like..
"We're filming now!" Yes! first question
How often does Marzia get recognized?
By now we don't really
Leave the house. We don't leave the house. --We don't leave the house!
Now when it's really like in busy days or busy times.
But if we do go out when it's like a weekend, for example, I think maybe a few times a day?
But not as much you. Usually when someone recognizes me or us, they'll come to me first and then they're like (squeeky Voice) Marzia you come too in the selfie. It happens the opposite too
At the Blue Lagoon, yeah, the person came to me. She was like 'Marzia!' and then they were like 'Oh Felix.'
They seemed to make an effort even to be like 'Oh Marzia, I love Marzia so much Marzia is the the best YouTuber!'
Keep doing that. I wish-- Hahahhaha
Favorite spread to put on bread?
Nutella
I knew that. what is mine? Nothing!
--Butter!
--Cause bread is for p-meow!
And (chef kurig gda)  you put on the (connect the bra) and thats all you need baby. (yelles something irrelevant.)
yAAAAAAAA
Felix, Isn't our child beautif...
Wait you should do your voice. Felix isn't our child beautiful? (Same thing)To the ranch!! To the ranch with the child.
They got your expression, right. That's 99% of the time you looking at me like that.
Have you both learned Japanese yet? (Says something in Japanese) No, I just been listening to like err err
A a pod- it's like a audio or something.
But yeah, we will learn we will get on it. How are Edgar Maya? I miss seeing them in videos. Aww. They're great! they are great
Maya's sitting right there.
I'm not grabbing Edgar though cus I don't know where he (gasps) He's behind us! He's passed out.
Aww Maya.
Hey guys whats up? It's been a long time no one cares that I left the channel too.
*actual pterodactyl noise*
here's a good one. Does Marzia have legs..too?
Too?
-Too as in as well. Yeah but you don‘t have them.
-shock and disbelief -
Moving on-hey, theres Edgar!  Arrrr! Hey guys wassup?
After proposing to Marzia in Japan, are you guys planning on getting married there or in any other countries you were born?
We thought about Japan. We thought about everywhere on the planet basically hehe.
Really like the idea of eloping and going to Japan. But the more I looked into it. It's hard. The more complicated it seems
We didn't know what we were getting into
It's like oh you can go here and we're like well what happens over there?
But we have decided and it's a secret. Do they know? No, it's a secret
Mm-hm. But everything is set. *Pewds being bad boy not telling us*
Maybe in Argentina. Japan trip when, when Marzia?
Soon, Marzia very soon. Are you jealous?
Will you please Marzia's camera to film these instead of yours. We are! You're welcome internet what's wrong with my camera?
Thats why I had to set it up. Look at this quality terrible quality. hahaha
I think its cuz you don't care.
Ah. (oof) I mean your quality is  good
No, I'm not gonna sit here. You need to produce my video yeah, will you invite any other YouTubers to the wedding?
A few but we're keeping the guest list very very small. So if you're a YouTuber and your not invited. That means we hate you
hmm totally.
Hi, this is from swebliss clearly a fan of Sweden
Why did you move from Sweden and have you ever thought about moving back here? Why did we move Marzia?
We wanted a place where we could both speak and be independent.
because in Italy you'd have to lean on me  in Sweden I'd have to lean on you.
Yeah, so  Uk seemed  like a pretty in between kinda place a middle ground, basically
But we really cherished the time we had in Sweden because that's where we got
Maya and yeah, that's it was a humble beginnings in Sweden. I loved it. er
I think about going back to Sweden. Yeah, but I think if that happened it would be in the future. How's Dogy?
How is Dogy? He's great. He's doing great. I dont want to wake him up but
He sleeps during the day hehehahe
doggies alive
unlike Slippy.
Doggy's very cute. He just sleeps all the time! I Well I play with him. Next car maybe??
(ooh) You don't like that design. You don't like this design. Uh, it's cool. Maybe not on a car
When will your wife host meme review? Well first we have to get married. That is the requirement.
I have to be married to everyone that hosts meme review. No no no it says WIFE. Ohh. Thought you knew about
Shapiro. What was your dream job as a kid? this is for you though. No I think its for both.
I wanted to open a boutique and it was mostly for fashion but boutique still stands.
Boutique still stands, maybe a Maì shop in the future? Perhaps.
This video was sponsored by Maì shop. I wanted to make video games. Oh, yeah, but I had no idea what that meant
I was like, yeah sure and then I realized ehh
Youtuber
Why isn't the camera focused on me?
Because I'm the more important one.
haha
How do you feel Marzia, after quitting YouTube? I feel... good
The first two months when I first quit, I really missed it a lot. Mm-hmm
You missed what?  making videos, editing but also sharing things.
I feel like I still share them but I miss being able to have a platform what I could speak about anything
I want it in the same way
But at the same time it has given me what I wanted, which is the time to focus on something else
So it's good to have that. Feels good, man
Can you speak Italian Felix? No, Italian is too hard for me because I am a pug. Bork. Marzia is a better youtuber
Oh yeah thats....very good Italian. *Sarcasm Intensifies*
Are you pizza? 'Un' pizza yes . Yeah see hehehahe. Its 'una' pizza, but yes I am.
Sei bellissima, Marzia (You are beautiful, Marzia)
Thank you.
Che bella! (Beautiful!) Ma dai! (Come on!)
Okay, this is one is for me but you should read it for me.
Bang marry kill Brad 1,Brad 2 -and Marzia. Alright, this is easy, kill Marzia
Bang Brad 1 Marry Brad 2. What are some of your favorite games to play together off camera? Well, we don't play any games on camera.
So.. All of them
We play(ed) Yoshy together on camera.Oh Yeah well but not anymore.
We play pokemon cards, Magic. Then some video games we play.... We usually play switch games
Overcooked is good, Smash Bros. Smash Bros is good. Ah don't know the  name everybody thinks its my favorite game.
Drum and fun, drum and fun. Yeah. That's really fun.
Like that, and you have the legs that you can kick. Oh that game yeah, that was fun I don't remember what its called.
That one
And Of course nutaku games my favorite central for video games say the coupon code
Pewdiepie20. that's it, Pewdiepie20. That's the coupon code. How did you know that?
Will you propose to Marzia the second time in Minecraft? And any chance, recording it?
Well, as you can see, I've set up a computer here Marzia. It's time to play minecraft.
Imagine if a creeper was our like priest explodes and kills us. Do you feel you've made it in life now you're basically best pals with Elon?
Can you just stop shaking I cant read! Oh yeah! Oh yeah! That is my answer.
Fe Male Wo Man Hu Man Per son whats Her?
Dishwasher. It's very lame,next one. The joke here was that I'm the one who put everything in the dishwasher
They thought it could be an educational moment here for everyone here
That you can learn that men can use the dishwasher too - okay. I use the dishwasher all the time
I prefer hand-washing.
You're more of a hand washing girl and there's nothing wrong with that. Mmm thank you.
Nothing wrong with it. Maybe before we were married, I would shame(we're not ma) but now I've educated myself.
This is from anime man Joey.
Who's your waifu?
Maya for me. Awww. Who is it?
Mayaaaa.
Sure Sure. I don't have a waifu you are wife my future waifu. You always have girl crushes okay? Don't even @ me.
No I totally do. It will be fine if you said a name. here you got a question for Marzia.
Do you really think he is the one? I mean, really, you've got better men outside (hehe), who have a job and regularized monetized salary.
Yeah, but it is more than money. You know? Like charm and good looks. [haha funny joke felix]
Like being funny. Dude, I was rated top five, Marzia. Here's a tough one.
If you could marry Elon Musk, would you choose him over Marzia? We're already engaged. ;)
Sorry Marzia this is the reason I put you on camera because I want people to know. Thankyou.
Like the bachelor.
Like the bachelor?
Yeah! When he broke off the engag...
*GaSp* He broke off the engagement?!
More questions
Do you want more 'cause that was all the questions. Okay well then BYE!
Well, well, well, well, Thank You Marzia.
That was really smooth
For being here. Your welcome. But also for being my future wife. Of course.
Everyone is invited to the wedding *GASP* Us caption authors too?!??
Check your inbox everyone that subscribes
Are invited it's gonna be lit. We're not giving out any details, right?
You're just inviting. But you're invited. You won't know when, where, or how but... see you there.
Make sure you smash like subscribe and also
Marzia the floor is yours - Millions of people watching. Ummm.
What do you want? What? Putting you on the spot smash like, subscribe. Buy all the merch.(Bring back cyka blyat merch)
[Help a bro out and Sub to Pewdiepie If you haven't already, also screw T-Series (T-Gay) and unsubscribe to them.] Peace.